falls es am sonntag aber doch nicht gut
laufen sollte für reiner haseloff hat er
die erklärung längst parat er sagt die
afg hat unter anderem deswegen erfolg
weil die eher linken parteien die
falschen themen in den mittelpunkt der
debatte stellen und explizit nennt
haseloff das gendern afd wählt ist in
dieser logik notwehr gegen das zu ändern
sie wissen schon gender in dieser
neumodische quatsch der uns neuerdings
aufgezwungen wird das doch früher auch
nicht freundinnen es ist feierabend
guck mal der alte kohli verkappter für
minister hätte ich ihm gar nicht
zugetraut
andererseits hieß sein erfolgreichste
show wir erinnern uns einer wird
gewinnen es wurscht was für eine
entgleiste und hysterische debatte in
einigen deutschen behörden gibt es
leitlinien für geschlechtergerechte
sprache
das bedeutet wer arbeitet soll sich in
der schriftsprache möglichst um
entsprechende sensibilität bemühen
daraus wird die heraufziehende gender
diktatur zwingt uns die deutsche sprache
zu schänden oder es heißt haben wir denn
keine anderen sorgen freunde ja
definitiv haben wir andere sorgen nur
verwendet die politik in wirklichkeit
auch gar nicht so viel zeit und energie
aus thema gender wenn man nach rechnet
und auch den meisten leuten da draußen
im land ist der angeblich so gefährliche
und fasste gender stern herzlich egal
gar nix gefrorenes zeichen kälte richtig
das ist das gefroren zeichne das kennen
wir auch verpackungen der tiefkühl ware
von bo frösteln und eis frau tatsächlich
kennen wir deutschen ja schon seit
jahrhunderten ich sage nur generisches
maskulinum bei becker soll sich die
bäckerin gefälligst mit gemeint fühlen
weil wir das immer so gemacht haben sich
da auf dauer mal was inklusive es zu
überlegen und ich sage gar nicht der
bofrost sternzeit auch schon die
optimale lösung
das hat ja nichts mit ideologie zu tun
sondern schlicht mit höflichkeit
wenigstens mal drüber nachdenken statt
sich über konstruierten quatsch lustig
zu machen
jetzt hätte ich meine das beispiel
kinder ihre innen genommen büßergewand
oder wahrscheinlich korrekt büßer
sternchen gewand passivraucher gender
hicks in den schutz verordnung und die
supranationalen neutrum und die diversen
sternchen iks ja vielen dank für
sternchen gar nix lady gaga ganz kurzer
disclaimer wird ihnen aufgefallen sein
ich selber gender nicht und bemühen sich
stattdessen um neutrale formulierungen
wie pflegepersonal oder ich sage halt
pfleger und pflegerinnen warum weil ich
finde dass ist mein ansonsten so
unglaublich eleganten sprachlos stört
selbstverständlich habe ich aber null
probleme damit wenn andere länder
ich verstehe die idee dahinter
jedenfalls deutlich besser als
wehleidige ski gaudi wie das hier
wie soll man das gender sternchen
sprechen
das binnen-i dem unterstrich das kann
man nicht sprechen ja dann lass es doch
einfach lieber so zum gandalf fakt ist
doch sprache entwickelt sich die
verändert sich ununterbrochen und was
die menschen nicht annehmen das wird
sich am ende sowieso nicht durchsetzen
mit zwang geht da gar nichts in einer
aktuellen umfrage sind 65 prozent der
deutschen gegen zu ändern aber eine
mehrheit ist eben auch gegen einen
gender verbot für behörden
sie wollten lustig oder das gender
gegner die sonst überall sprach
polizei und verbote wittern hier ein
verbot fordern sowie der hamburger cdu
chef christoph ploß oder wilder gar kein
verbot
die staatlichen einrichtungen sollten
sich an die deutsche grammatik hatten
das heißt wenn sie es tun und das tun
sie ja häufig also denn dann würden sie
es verbieten wird unterbinden das ganz
was anderes ja nicht verbieten einfach
nur gewaltsam unterbinden
derweil berichten bestimmte medien in
einer art endlosschleife über tragische
fälle wie den von lukas ohne man cdu
jungpolitiker und student in kassel
er hat stellen sie sich vor eine
schlechtere note gekriegt weil er in
einer arbeit nicht geändert hat
also fasst tatsache ist die arbeit wurde
gar nicht benotet und er hat bestanden
aber so ist die geschichte halt
langweilig studien beweisen werden
kindern berufe in er
geschlechtergerechte sprache präsentiert
trauen sich mädchen eher jobs zu die
traditionell männern zugeordnet werden
tatsächlich ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
höher dass sich frauen bewerben wenn
berufsbezeichnungen in ausschreibung
explizit auch weiblich formuliert sind
andererseits der sprachwandel besonders
der dramatische wandel also der
strukturelle wandel der wird betrieben
durch die volonté générale der
sprachgemeinschaft da kann noch nicht
irgendeine gleichstellungsbeauftragte
kommen und sagen ich mach's besser als
der herrgott der herrgott schreibt den
duden stimmt das steht ja sogar schon in
den elf geboten
du sollst nicht ändern klar ob sprache
wirklich das denken oder gar die
gesellschaft verändert dass es durchaus
umstritten
und wer sagt equal pay ist zb
dringlicher denn der hat ein argument
allerdings kommt das argument oft von
leuten denen es komplett sturz ist dass
frauen immer noch weniger verdienen
generisches maskulinum ist halt gelernt
und wer eine dreht den spieß mal um
sowie unsere justizministerin letzten
herbst mit einem neuen gesetzentwurf zum
insolvenzrecht sie glauben gar nicht was
da um ein haben beinahe fast passiert
wäre
die deutsche sprache heimtückisch
ermordet
jetzt bei true sender kol
christine l sie sieht aus wie die metal
thermomix vertreterin von nebenan
doch vorsicht das hier ist die gemischte
frodo schloss sogar ihr musikgeschmack
macht angst
mein gott ist das kranke die ihre
christine hat versucht in deutschland
etwas einzuführen das viel schlimmer ist
als die scharia das generische religion
oder wie johann wolfgang von goethes
sagen würde nur noch schuldnerin oder
verbraucherin heißt ein ganzes
geschlecht käme sprachlich gar nicht
mehr vor und zwar das wichtigste
geschlecht völliger wahnsinn
doch der plan der durchgeknallten gender
hexe wurde in letzter minute verhindert
vom ältesten und weißen mann der große
vielfalt halt danke post in diesem
kabinett dürfen frauen nie wieder
alleine gesetze schreiben richtig so
denn nur männer kennen sich wirklich aus
mit grammatik
wirklich immer wieder faszinierend wie
aggressiv diese debatte geführt wird oft
mit dem sub text kümmert euch mal lieber
um die probleme der normalen statt um
personen bereiten außer großstadt
einiges was da im netz so ausgeklügelt
wird es fast schon kunst
burgschauspielerin bild schneider liest
original kurzprosa aus dem widerstand
gegen die kinder diktatur
meine damen und herren wir beginnen mit
konstruktiver zuschauer kritik marcel j
ist offenbar von beruf proktologie
deiner schreibt der gender bahn steckt
beim zdf aber sehr tief in der klemme
spannende theorie das würde natürlich
erklären warum claus kleber immer so
leicht schief im studio steht
trinks kombiniert elegant linguistische
einwände
mit subtilem rassismus wenn er anmerkt
ländern ist unnötiger als ein fundbüro
in polen
[Gelächter]
köstlich verstehen sie weil die polen
alle clown aber sie gender nicht der
user credit credit wagt sich derweil vor
in das feld der dadaistischen murex ich
scheiß auf dem tisch innen
wunderbar große kunst stellt immer
fragen hat der protagonist diese
geschichte in einem innenraum also auf
einem tisch innen groß gemacht oder ist
tisch innen doch anklagende persiflage
auf einer aus dem ruder gelaufene sprach
doktrin ich weiß es nicht und es ist mir
scheißegal
sven a m hat ebenfalls fragen was ist
mit generischen feminin um was ist mit
wörtern wie die war politesse note [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] dann will ich auch nutzer
ja du lieber sven wenn das wirklich ein
traum ist dann werd doch nutzer kauft
ihr einen wohnwagen und stell dich an
die b9 es ist ein freies land ein auto
namens der and gender hadert mit der
gender sprache ausweiten niveauvollen
gründen denn sie ist teil einer anti
freiheitlichen und anti
individualistischen agenda von
poststrukturalismus kritischer theorie
und internationalen feministinnen genau
was ich immer sage oder in den worten
von super holgi 69 fit alle
feministinnen
richtig aber wer hat die zeit und nun
zum gedenken aller opfer des gender
terrorismus lese ich alle namen der
menschen vor die in deutschland wegen
ihrer weigerung zu gendern entlassen
dienst rechtlich belangt oder schlechter
benotet wurden fertig guten abend so
aufnahme hallo
dies ist die automatische and cut von
oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich